جانب الروسي والجانب الاوكراني يؤكدون بان
القوات الاوكرانيه ما زالت تقاوم في مدينه
باخمر بالامس يعني
مؤسس قوات فاجنر قال بان الذين قتلوا
وارسلهم هم قاتلوا بشجاعه لكنهم قتلوا ذلك
في اشاره منه الى السيطره الروسيه او
سيطره قواته الخاصه على المنطقه بالفعل
قوات فاجنر طوقت مدينه باقمط من النواحي
الثلاث وتبقى الطريق الوحيد في المنطقه
الغربيه
بلدتي خرومافا وبغدانا حتى الان معارك
ضاريه في هذا المحور لكن لم يستطع الجيش
الروسي
اختراقها تاني البلدان القوات الاوكرانيه
تدافع من هذا المحور الغربي وصولا الى
منتصف المدينه دخلت القوات الروسيه في
العمق وسيطرت على احياء كثيره عده
كيلومترات هي المدينه صغيره اصلا دخلت عده
كيلومترات من جميع النواحي وصولا الى
المنتصف لم تستطع اختراق قلب المدينه الذي
يمتد للناحيه الغربيه وما زالت القوات
الاوكرانيه تسيطر على هذه المناطق وهو
الطريق الوحيد كما وصفه
بانه يمكن للقوات الاوكرانيه الانسحاب من
هنا كاشاره الى ان المهله التي منحها قائد
قوات فارنار
للانسحاب خلال يومين انتهت وعاده المعارك
لتستعر اكثر ولتكون اعنف واكثر الشراسه في
هذا المحور نعم رائد يعني دعنا نذكر بانه
اذا سيطرت القوات الروسيه على بخموت ما
الذي ستستفيده ميدانيا اتحدث تحديدا عن
الامدادات خطوط الامداد كيف ستستفيد من
ذلك وايضا لاحقا ما المناطق او المدن التي
يمكن ان تصبح سهله
السيطره عليها
بالفعل مدينه باخمت ليس لها ذات الاهميه
يعني
الماديه المقصود ليس فيها كنوز من الالماس
او الذهب او المصانع كما في مناطق اخرى في
دمباس او الحديد هي عباره عن مناجم للملح
ومصانع للكحول لكن الاهميه الاستراتيجيه
للمدينه لانها هي الحصن المانع امام المدن
الكبرى كراماتورسك
واسلافيانس وكذلك
قسطنطينه هذه المدن هامه جدا وهي الاكبر
في المحور الشمالي من المقاطعه كما ان نهر
هو الاكثر اهميه لايصال المياه العذبه الى
مناطق دمباس حيث تحتجزها القوات
الاوكرانيه خلف مدينه سلافيا سلافيان اذا
سيطر الجيش الاوكراني على باغموت يكون قد
فتح البوابه للمواجهه الرئيسيه مع هذه
المدن حيث تكمن هنا قواعد عسكريه كبيره
للقوات الاوكرانيه